the first night is never usually that
bad in any of game so I'll play through
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at Freddy's
for now this is the final chapter in the
five nights at Freddy's series and this
represents what Scott wants to be the
scariest game in the entire series and
this is such a big deal and it's dropped
on me like early in the morning so I had
to rush over here and get recording on
it but it necessitated the return of my
glasses also my mom told me that I
needed to put my glasses off because
apparently my face is too ugly five days
until the party what party
oh alright how's it going hey what did
he do this time well this is five nights
of Frick boys he locked you in your room
again don't be scared I'm here with you
oh oh oh okay
oh this is how we're gonna start off why
is foxy headless why's these are my
friends oh okay sure okay alright then
so who are you why is any of this
happening Oh Oh golden Freddy's eyes are
following me okay alright then so I got
locked in my room why why is any of this
also my mom didn't say that I was ugly
at all but I love my mom very much I run
my mom would never lock me in my room
all by myself hello oh no that's so sad
why is this happening Mauro is another
day is it I don't know if that's primary
concern right here okay Oh night one
okay cool
so so what it all right click here to
run to the door okay hello
whoa what the Oh was that what did i do
what did i do I did a thing oh no what
did i do what did i do was that
information oh no oh no oh no I didn't
know that I didn't read okay that does
that so that's the same button that did
the flashlight before cuz I remember
from the trailer but oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no I'm missing oh
I'm missing very valuable information
probably oh I'm gonna die in such
horrible ways oh no I'm gonna die in sin
so her boys okay
okay so there's a probably waited there
was a waited oh ah there we go
okay so from what I remember from the
trailer there was a few different zones
and I was trying to analyze the trailer
and I get an idea how the game was gonna
be so there's behind you which for some
reason you're not sitting on the actual
bed I guess cuz you have to run up and
do things and then there was like the
three things here so this is reminiscent
of the first games like office or any of
the games offices actually oddly enough
to kind of put myself in the mindset and
to try to get a true comparison as to
what is gonna happen
I actually replayed the first game the
first few nights of the first game so I
don't know what to expect from this one
but I definitely wanted to get an idea
of what came out last ones before I did
anything here was that what was that
this is a phone the phone no do phone
guy before no do foreign guy stuff oh
he's just weeks okay but I'm the
squeaker okay so I I'm just under the
assumption for some reason okay I was
locked in my room but this looks like
the room because that lamp there and
that dresser looks like the room for the
little what is that
why is my fan not going my purple van up
there in no go oh no oh no no no no no
no no
no no no no I don't even know what to
expect I'm pretty sure I missed out on
some very important instructions okay so
how do i how do I close the door I don't
know how to close the door like if
something's coming down the hallway how
do I close at hand our space no oh oh
okay shift okay that's important
information
oh that's important information well it
was like ah crap I have no idea what I'm
doing
I have no idea what I'm doing maybe
that's for the best
because maybe going into this totally
uninitiated is actually good for me for
some reason [ __ ] that
what was that oh okay ward off all the
monsters apparently what was that before
those little jibber-jabber dudes the
freddy jibber jabbers like that I don't
like that I don't like that at all so
far so nothing and I don't know what the
sound outside is it either sounds like
rain or someone's pulling up in the
driveway oh I don't know what that is
well maybe it's behind me supply me [ __ ]
you get out here what are you doing
disappearing into the wall son of a
[ __ ]
you're supposed to keep me safe Freddy
let's see me keep me safe didn't work
okay so those sounds are the sounds of
the little jibber jabbers behind me I
don't know what that is it's apparently
Fox he's in here
I closed that okay which is good at cats
it's like Foxy's curtains back from the
first game oh man if I had any guess as
to what Scott wanted to pull from for
this game it was definitely probably
from the first game but to kind of
completely turn the formula on his head
which kinda is what is going on here
because it's it's bizarre because
there's no camera checking it's all like
do I have a dog and and why is dog know
come protect me ok 5 a.m. so I'm pretty
close doing good but then the first get
out of here you son of a [ __ ]
Jesus ok so the first night is never
usually that bad in any of the game so
I'll play through [ __ ] what that's up oh
oh it's always what I'm saying something
it's always I'm oh I'll be ok Oh
everything's fine
Oh God maybe I can read the instructions
now I'll let me fast-forward through
this oh my god my heart oh god I didn't
even see what happened please let me out
of this hellhole why am I in this
hellhole why is any of this a hellhole
in the first place
why does a child's life have to be a
hellhole tomorrow is another day let's
just get through tonight shall we listen
carefully if you hear breathing oh ok if
you hear breathing hold the door shut if
you do not hear breathing then use your
flashlight ok alright now I get it now I
can play the game good for me the thing
is I don't know what the breathing
sounds like cuz I kind of I kind of
flicked on my flashlight too quickly and
I had no idea that there was gonna be
something there I'm pretty sure it was
chica I only stopped like a bear I
thought I saw a beak thrusting at me
from the darkness I have no idea what it
was it all went by too quickly and it's
definitely changing up everything that
I've knowed about playing before it's
really interesting well I'll have to
reserve judgment until I get later on in
the game and I find out more about
what's going on in terms of the lore and
everything else is happening what was
that close that is that a thing
okay okay man I'm gonna become a
marathon runner with all this sprinting
back and forth I'm doing we're okay for
him we're doing fine the night actually
seems to be going quicker than the past
night's probably because there's not as
much
who's that breathing oh I think I did
pretty dang oh I think I better heard
something no [ __ ] you
wait that was the face on the phone was
doing something different I could've
sworn wait it was might have been out of
the corner of my eye but it looked like
a phone face was a little different no
is chica in the kitchen chica in the
kitchen oh lucky no lucky I know lucky a
lot Sakuya oh boy
you don't like you gotta clear the pest
from my desk or my bed my damn bed my
deathbed Oh
hey reading I didn't hear any breathing
there was no breathing no over anything
all right I gotta get through the first
night geez I gotta get through the first
night I'm guessing I can just be a
little more patient unchecking that with
my flashlight I get it yes okay yeah I
get it we just let me be sad for a bit
I'm probably the warp right now of all
the people that got the debye probably I
probably the worst cuz I've died twice
on the first night my crown is slipping
from my head Oh No
why gods in five nights did everybody
okay
it's so like nerve-racking to go down in
the door and not know whether they're
there or not Oh eyes are you okay okay
okay okay okay okay that was a thing I
just it's just like I don't think that's
breathing but you never know
hi go away please thank you okay so
Oh Oh
that was the breathing oh I didn't know
that was it oh god okay so it's not
breathing it's a freaking radio god damn
it
oh I am so bad at this
oh why am I so bad okay I know what the
breathing is now it's any noise that's
not the normal noise it's it's weird
it's it's really weird about it it's
that moment of apprehension that's like
right before I turn on the flashlight
every single time I'm like is it I'm
pretty sure but is it oh god if that was
the intention that was well done just
the little moment of hesitation like the
am I going to die if I do this and I
will die instantly the first time I
tried this it was easy I got the 5 a.m.
I didn't even try uh I didn't even read
the instructions for am okay just come
on to get to 6 a.m. damn it it's a first
night I should be able to witness under
king of something Oh get out here 5 a.m.
come on I just gotta get to 5 a.m.
Oh 6 a.m. I mean okay
we're fine it's gonna go up here and
shut the door here I mean that might be
mom making me a tasty sandwich no what
was that why did it blink me that menu
get when he went away you know
closed closed it was closed geez I need
to like have a better understanding
about the basic fundamentals of this or
else I'm never gonna get through this
I'm never gonna get through to the later
the game unless I actually understand
like the specifics of this so I need the
specifics of it my thought is maybe I
got to the door too late anyway because
he was down the hall I saw him which
meant that he was coming that way so
what that meant for me is that I needed
to be more vigilant on that door period
but I I went to the other door and I
kind of hid away from it I tried to
avoid it but what I needed to do is
probably go over there and quickly shut
the door
then I I don't know how long I hold the
door is the question
oh hey okay so there's a chica down here
cheese
chicas down here okay go check behind me
clear them off okay
no chicas down there so breathing okay
so I gotta check the other side lonnie-
snuck up is that laughing so chica might
still be coming up on the right side
okay okay we're okay okay I think we're
okay nobody nobody boo boo boo boo boo
boo I think I won I think I got it I
think I'm okay yeah yeah what the hell
is that doing whoa I did it okay Wow Wow
okay so the trick is you have to be
proactive you have to be as proactive as
possible in what you're doing you have
to actively try to do what you need to
do so either way that is the first night
of five nights at Freddy's 4 this is
going to be amazing because if if if
they add a lot more to the game on top
of this this could be a phenomenal game
it's so scary it's great I love this I
can't wait to play more so the demo
isn't out for public but the real game
might come out very soon because in the
past whenever a demo got released to
like the youtubers it pretty soon after
the full game got released for everybody
so stay tuned for that thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think of this game in the
comments down below and as always I will
see you
in the next video
I
you know I feel a deeper connection over
looking at each other yeah